[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines tout de suite
les titres de ce lundi 24 avril
[Musique]
la phase cachée de la politique en
Île-de-France est ce que promet de
révéler Babette de Rosières dans son
livre qui paraîtra le 27 avril prochain
clientélisme méthode de gestion promesse
non tenue la conseillère régionale et
chef de cuisine yvinoise dévoile les
coulisses du pouvoir et notamment ses
relations tumultueuses avec la
présidente de l'Île-de-France Valérie
Pécresse Babette de Rosière et notre
invité
ils étaient plus de 350 coureurs à
fouler la ligne de départ pour sa
quatrième édition dimanche 23 avril à
Trappes la commune organisait un
semi-marathon et une course de 10 km
avec 80% du parcours en pleine nature à
l'île de loisirs et 20% dans les rues de
Trappes nous étions sur place
et enfin comme chaque lundi nous verrons
les résultats sportifs du week-end dont
parlera football et notamment avec la
victoire du FC Versailles contre ses
dents ou le club de handball à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui a perdu
contre le sbbr handball Béthune
et en plateau avec nous Michael et le
midoro bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
journaliste sport de la rédaction TV 78
et comme je l'ai dit avec vous nous
verrons les résultats sportifs du
week-end dans notre page sport mais en
attendant vous restez un petit peu avec
nous je ne bouge pas régime super et en
face de vous Babette de Rosières bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes chef de cuisine
et vous êtes également femme politique
car vous êtes depuis 2015 conseillère
régional d'Île-de-France vous avez écrit
notamment cet ouvrage donc la face
cachée de la politique en Île-de-France
c'est un livre critique sur les
coulisses du pouvoir qui paraîtra le 27
avril prochain aux éditions orphi alors
vous avez déjà publié 27 livres de
cuisine et une autobiographie pourquoi
avoir eu envie d'écrire sur la politique
je suis généreux c'est normal que
j'écrive un peu cela politique lorsque
je suis rentré en politique j'avais une
idée très précise de la politique je
pensais que la politique c'était comme
la vie de tous les jours donc quand
Valérie me chercher ça a duré longtemps
parce qu'elle est venue en 2000 c'était
2014 pour l'élection 2015 donc ce que
j'aime avec elle c'est que elle est plus
qu'il y a elle est têtue quand elle veut
quelque chose elle va jusqu'au bout
c'est pas quelqu'un qui recule et ça
j'aime ça parce que c'est un peu mon ADN
moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui renonce je
suis quelqu'un qui fonce et j'ai aimé ça
avec elle parce qu'elle est plusieurs
fois chez moi au restaurant elle a pris
des prétexte et cetera de prétexte
à diversité de mariage j'en passe et
finalement mon mari m'a dit de ne pas y
aller oui
et après avoir fait l'expérience d'une
première manature je me suis rendu
compte que la politique que je croyais
parce que je pense qu'en politique c'est
un don de soi c'est pour les autres et
j'ai pas ressenti ça c'est vraiment
après avoir mieux me réfléchi je me suis
dit je vais je vais je vais faire
quelque chose c'est pas possible
n'hésitez pas on va en
on va garder nos téléspectateurs un peu
dans le dans le suspense justement à
côté de vous on a Philippe Philippe
montaudoin
bonsoir Philippe Montaudon donc vous
êtes le président du club Conflans
Andrésy Jouy volley-ball et avec vous
nous ferons le point justement sur la
saison Elite vous avez gagné la Coupe de
France fédérale il y a un peu plus d'une
semaine ce que vous êtes toujours sur
votre petit nuage
un petit peu mais en fait on est en
train de fêter ça avec nos partenaires
priez et public donc on descend pas
vraiment c'est on va essayer de fêter ça
le plus longtemps possible parce que
c'est tellement dur à aller chercher
on en reparlera plus amplement tout à
l'heure bonsoir Céline Charles bonsoir
vous êtes également journaliste de
l'érection de la rédaction TV 78 et dans
un instant avec vous ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines et ce sera juste après les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
le temps sera nuageux demain matin avec
des éclaircies dans tout le département
selon Météo France au niveau des
températures il fera encore un peu frais
le matin comptez 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 7° à Versailles et ou
dans et 6 degrés à Rambouillet on
retrouvera les mêmes conditions à météo
dans l'après-midi et du côté des
températures elles aussiont entre 11
degrés et 12 degrés dans tout le
département et demain nous fêterons la
Saint Marc le point à présent sur
l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence les informations du jour
avec vous Céline et c'est informations
une un hommage a été rendu ce matin à
Stéphanie montfermei victime d'un
attentat devant le commissariat de
Rambouillet il y a deux ans oui
souvenez-vous Régine le 23 avril 2021
Stéphanie montfernet fonctionnaire de
police âgé de 49 ans a été assassiné à
coup de couteau par un terroristique
islamiste devant l'entrée du
commissariat de Rambouillet 2 ans après
un nouvel hommage lui a été rendu devant
le commissariat stéphanie montfermé a
reçu à titre posthume la médaille des
victimes du terrorisme et on continue
les informations du jour avec la
signature d'une convention de
partenariat au château de
Maisons-Laffitte entre Transilien SNCF
voyageur et le Comité Régional de
Tourisme Paris Île-de-France oui une
convention qui officialise la
coopération engagée entre les deux
parties et qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
du lancement de la saison 2023 de c'est
pas loin en train alors c'est pas loin
en train qu'est ce que c'est bien c'est
une initiative qui propose aux
francilien comme au touristes de
découvrir le patrimoine de
l'Île-de-France à portée de train et
moindre coût l'idée de présenter une
palette de parcours et de sites
touristiques franciliens accessible avec
les lignes de RER train et tram train
opéré par Transilien SNCF écouter c'est
la première signature d'une convention
avec le Transilien et les SNCF en
général et il est là pour mettre en
place un plan d'action pour développer
ce qu'on appelle le tourisme durable
nous visons deux choses d'abord que les
agents chargés de la relation clientèle
en gare les agents Transiliens
connaissent et soit formés pour
utilement orienter francilien
provinciaux et étranger vers ces sites
et d'autre part pour travailler avec le
Comité Régional du Tourisme à la
problématique du dernier kilomètre il y
a énormément de belles choses proches
d'une gare il faut un petit peu marcher
mais pas très loin et puis il y a des
choses qui sont un peu plus éloignées
et pour lutter contre la désertification
médicale le département des Yvelines
installe 8 nouvelles cabines de
télémédecine et oui Régine comme vous le
savez le département des Yvelines est de
plus en plus touché par la
désertification médicale notamment dans
les communes les plus rurales pour
lutter contre ce manque de médecin le
département officialisé en octobre 2022
le lancement d'un projet de télémédecine
de cette année 50 dispositifs de
téléconsultation médicale et un bus
itinérant vont être déployés un peu
partout sur le territoire 8 cabines de
télémédecine ont déjà vu le jour à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine Les Mureaux
Mantes-la-Jolie Mantes-la-Ville Meulan
en Yvelines Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
Rambouillet un projet d'un coup global
prévisionnel de 10 millions d'euros les
détails au micro de Julien Leroy vous
êtes prise en charge par un médecin dès
que vous avez introduit votre carte
Vitale et à partir de ce moment là le
médecin commence à consultation avec les
instruments qu'il a qui sont dispositifs
médicaux classe 2A depuis des
instruments minéraux à des instruments
de spécialités comme la dermatologie
l'ORL mais également
l'électrocardiogramme et peut donc ainsi
faire sa consultation il rentre en
contact avec le patient fait son
interrogatoire jusqu'à l'ordonnance
c'était le cabine ne sont pas conçus
comme un remplacement des médecins
libéraux c'est au contraire en
complémentarité à la fois dans les
secteurs où il y a pas de médecins
libéraux il y a plus donc on les
installera et puis là où les médecins
libéraux sont un peu surchargés ça sera
le moyen de faire un premier filtre
et le centre de secours situé sur la
commune de Magny-les-Hameaux recrute des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires pour
renforcer ses équipes oui si vous avez
entre 17 ans et 55 ans et que vous êtes
bien sûr disponible au Centre de Secours
vous attend au sein de la caserne une
vingtaine de sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et une cinquantaine de sa
porte-pompiers volontaire réalise près
de 2600 interventions par an
majoritairement du secours à la personne
et des missions incendie pour postuler
ou pour plus de renseignements vous
pouvez directement contacter la caserne
les coordonnées s'affichent en bas de
l'écran et une bonne nouvelle pour les
habitants de Beynes le bureau de poste
de la ville restera finalement ouvert
tout à fait Régine en janvier dernier le
maire de Beynes Yves révèle avait évoqué
la transformation prochaine du bureau de
poste de la ville la direction de la
société de la Poste avait en effet
décidé de fermer ce lieu de service
public une décision qui était loin
d'avoir fait l'unanimité auprès des
habitants et au sein de la mairie la
municipalité c'est d'ailleurs fortement
mobilisé pendant plusieurs mois et ses
efforts ont fini par payer le maire de
la ville a annoncé lors d'une lettre
d'information à l'attention de ses
habitants le maintien du bureau et bien
merci beaucoup Céline Charles pour ses
actualités et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas
à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission Babeth
de Rosières vous êtes notre invité et on
va parler de politique ce soir voilà
puisque vous avez justement je le redis
encore une fois vous allez publier la
face cachée de la politique en
Île-de-France alors dans ce livre vous
racontez notamment vos premiers pas dans
la politique donc c'était un monde avec
lequel vous étiez longtemps resté
éloigné et je vous cite d'ailleurs la
seule politique qui m'intéressait
c'était mon restaurant et mes émissions
de télévision qui me permettaient de
pouvoir de promouvoir les produits de
mon île et densité les téléspectateurs à
venir découvrir ma cuisine
exactement et pourtant vous y êtes lancé
et votre mari Claude butin ancien
magistrat était contre quel regard
justement portez-vous sur la politique
mon mari m'a déconseillé mais je vous
disais que Valérie venait me voir
d'ailleurs avant Valérie il y a Patrick
arôme qui n'a pas cessé de m'appeler
pour me dire il faut Valérie c'est la
politique etc tu verras tu as ta place
tu es une femme connue et puis d'un
moment tu représentes les outre-mer il
faut absolument qu'ils soient politiques
bon pas plus que ça ça me parle plus
grand chose mais jusqu'au jour où il
s'est déplacer elle est venue elle est
venue une première fois une deuxième
fois une troisième fois et à chaque fois
c'était un déjeuner ou un dîner ou un
anniversaire on fait bref elle a été mis
dans votre restaurant et puis finalement
un jour j'ai déjà mon mari pourquoi pas
parce que quand on s'engage en politique
c'est pour les autres c'est pas pour
soi-même parce que moi j'ai mon métier
j'ai plusieurs casquettes d'ailleurs
donc pourquoi pas alors du coup j'ai dit
à Valérie je viens le jour je lui ai dit
que je veux c'est un feu d'artifice
alors après non est passé on n'a pas
porté sur plein de choses et m'a dit de
toute façon je te donnerai une
vice-présidente à la Cité de la
gastronomie la cité de gastronomie je
connaissais pas parce que bon elle m'a
dit c'était la soumis qu'entre temps le
Bulgar solomi pour moi c'est c'est le
bonheur parce que c'est mon métier et
qui dit cuisine qui dit Gaston musique
restaurant je suis en pleine dedans donc
évidemment les élections se passent moi
on me prend comme un pion au même on
emmène partout Stéphanie donne l'ordre
surtout vous n'allez nulle part sans
Babette il faut que Babette soit partout
d'ailleurs tous les petits codes du
fichiers les broches et tout ça il y
avait Valérie Babette c'est un vanille
chocolat
c'est comme ça qu'elle vous plaisait
quand j'allais par exemple tout le
marché et les gens je vote pour bébé je
veux pas pourquoi mais moi je suis venu
avec le chocolat
intéressant aussi chez vous c'est que
vous avez une idée transpartisanale de
la politique parce que c'est pas terminé
et puis finalement les élections on
arrive à la distribution d'État
vice-président vice-présidente président
après je vois délégué délégué et la
dernière personne la dernière alors que
moi j'étais la première devant pour
faire la politique avec elle la dernière
c'est pas bête préfiguration à la Cité
de la gastronomie c'est une douche
froide alors préfiguration je dis ça
commence bien promesse non tenue je
voulais régler mes comptes tout de suite
le jour de la réunion et puis dis donc
je vais me retenir j'étais après mais ne
t'inquiète pas tu verras de toute façon
ça change le vice-président ça tourne et
tout ça tu verras et à chaque fois
c'était des promesses non tenues à
chaque fois j'allais en catastrophe en
catastrophe comment je voulais que je me
suis déplacée par des voir cette cité
cette fameuse cité des gastronomie j'ai
vu un endroit faire avec des des
bâtiments vétus etc et je me suis
renseignée ça faisait 10 ans qu'on était
sur ce projet là et le projet de me voir
le jour en 2025 Didier se foutu de moi
elle m'a donné alors c'est une coquille
vide et c'est là que tout a commencé et
c'est là que j'ai commencé à comprendre
que la politique c'est de belles paroles
avant on vous aime on vous chouchoute on
vous bichonne et puis une fois que vous
êtes dedans alors là les pots de banane
commence
à me laisser parler jusqu'au bout on
demande une assistante on a pas on
demande des moyens pour travailler on a
pas on n'a pas de budget si tu es
gastronomie en préfiguration devant j'ai
rien à faire et donc j'ai décidé de
construire un parcours de la gastronomie
et c'est là que j'ai commencé à
travailler j'ai dit je prends les
devants je fais un parcours et là je
vais faire six sites autour de
l'Île-de-France pour parler de la
gastronomie pour mettre en valeur
l'agroalimentaire les chefs etc parce
que c'est comme mon cœur le métier voilà
mais la politique ce que je dis dans mon
livre c'est un constat que j'ai fait
c'est pas ni un règlement de compte ni
de j'ai pas de différence à régler j'ai
constaté des choses et moi il me doit de
dire les choses pour prévenir les
électeurs en leur disant la personne que
vous voyez devant vous avec le beau
visage et tout ça qui fait des pommettes
méfiez-vous parce que derrière quand on
gratte c'est pourri et justement c'est
un message que vous adressez à vos
lecteurs et vous parlez justement de
face cachée de la politique et justement
vous dénoncer aussi le clientélisme vous
avez notamment vous avez notamment parlé
de d'Othman Nasro qui est actuellement
vice-président du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France et qui aurait engagé
selon vous dire des rabatteurs pour
écrire des places de football au parc de
Prince
alors
vous allez voir tout ce qui est dedans
je suis pas là pour vous faire la
litanie de ce que j'ai écrit vous allez
voir et le dire c'est très intéressant
parce que non seulement autre chose
aussi il y a des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus graves dans le livre
et moi dans ma cavité d'élus je pense
que je suis obligée de dénoncer des
choses qui vont pas à la fois pour me
protéger mais à la fois aussi pour
ouvrir les yeux des personnes qui
croient à la politique mais c'est pas
pour ça que je ferai pas de la politique
parce que j'ai un œil très appuyé sur la
politique
est-ce que vous avez été déçu
par la présidente
politique grâce à Chirac je suis même
plus c'était pas né c'était
quelque chose qui me plaît beaucoup mais
j'étais déçu par le fonctionnement de
Madame Pécresse parce que elle quand on
est en voiture avec sa petite tête de
côté gentil souriante et tout ça c'est
une personne complètement antipathique
qui n'aime pas les gens aiment qu'elle
quand elle t'aime va faire attention
parce que elle a quelque chose à gratter
toi qu'elle a quelque chose à gratter
elle t'adore mais une fois que tu as
pressé comme un site qu'on a enlevé tout
le jus et te jette et ça il y a beaucoup
de mes collègues qui m'entendent qui
seront malheureusement eux ils peuvent
pas dire ce que je dis moi aujourd'hui
mais ils savent que c'est très difficile
avec avec Madame Pécresse c'est très
compliqué il faut rentrer dans les rangs
moi je conseille si je il me faut
qualifier ça je dirais que je suis je
suis rentré dans une secte
vous avez un gourou j'avais des adeptes
et des adeptes et que sinon rien d'autre
que la politique ben c'est oui oui oui
tout ce qu'on dit ils n'ont pas une
liberté de parole comme moi ils n'ont
pas une liberté de penser moi je prends
ma liberté de penser moi j'étais échappé
de la meute et donc aujourd'hui
vous n'avez plus contact aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas le contraire avec elle mais je
suis pas fâché avec Valérie je n'ai pas
de problème personnel avec elle moi je
suis je suis axée sous la politique il
faut pas tromper les électeurs quand
vous allez voter pour quelqu'un le vote
c'est un c'est un acte citoyen tu dois
pas tromper ton électorat on peut pas
dire à son électorat oui je fais une
deuxième mandature je vais jusqu'au bout
de ma mandature et deux mois après tu te
présentes à la présidentielle c'est
promesse non tenue moi j'ai j'ai
supporté des choses jusqu'au moment où
je dis stop
voilà et c'est pour ça que le 8 mars
2022 j'ai quitté carrément j'ai claqué
la porte de la campagne de Valérie
Pécresse parce que la campagne était ni
feignasse il y avait pas il y avait pas
d'armes il y a pas d'amour il y a pas de
cœur c'était hors sol je comprenais pas
cette campagne je me sentais plus à
cette place là donc voilà j'ai quitté la
campagne voilà pour ces raisons là et
vous pensez qu'elle va réagir comment va
les répéterresse quand elle va lire ce
que vous avez écrit je m'en fiche
complètement c'est pas mon problème
c'est très bien que tout ce que j'ai
écrit c'est prouvé et c'est la vérité et
encore je suis modéré je suis très très
bon mais je n'ai rien contre elle c'est
une femme bon j'ai envie qu'elle
réussisse c'est pas ça mais il faut pas
tromper les gens il faut pas raconter
n'importe quoi faut pas dire voilà tu
vas faire ça etc et puis derrière dis
non non tu fais rien du tout parce que
ce que je souhaite le mieux c'est qu'il
vote pour moi non tu peux pas traiter
les gens comme ça il y a plein de mes
collègues qui sont dans des situations
compliquées qui souffrent et qui disent
rien ils sont obligés parce qu'ils n'ont
que ça à la politique mais moi ma
liberté c'est quoi c'est mon couteau mon
tablier je vais dans le monde entier je
travaille et justement en parlant de ça
ce que vous allez continuer la politique
mais bien sûr
quand on fait la politique c'est un
engagement personnel c'est pour les
autres c'est pas pour être un
escapotable c'est pas pour entendre une
serviette c'est pas pour atteindre un
poste on fait la politique pour être
utile quand j'ai monté le parcours de la
gastronomie le premier qui a le premier
site qui a été ouvert qui est là qui est
formidable c'est l'hôtel de la Marine
mais il y avait Versailles il y avait ça
toi et Valérie je n'ai pas dépensé un
centime cela coûté ça coûtait 0 fois la
région c'est que les promoteurs qui ont
investi dans leur site et moi
j'apportais la publicité la
reconnaissance véhiculer un peu ce site
un peu partout dans le monde avec le
tourisme c'est ça que je voulais faire
et c'est d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
j'ai accepté une deuxième mandature
c'est pour poursuivre le parcours que
j'avais commencé parce que c'est mon
métier et je sais que c'est que du
bonheur qu'on donne aux gens dans ce
métier là la restauration la gastronomie
tout ça c'est du bonhomme bah c'est mon
métier je je vis ça comme je veux pas
vous dire je vais jamais quitter ça et
la politique non plus et ce bonheur vous
allez continuer justement à lui donner
vous le à la fin de votre livre que vous
avez aussi vous allez peut-être
reprendre des émissions télévisées
aussi vous savez j'ai commencé la
télévision j'avais 19 ans j'ai 45 ans de
télévision derrière moi j'ai jamais
quitté j'ai quitté parce que Valérie
venu me chercher pour me dire de venir
avec elle en politique là j'ai quitté la
télévision pour elle donc c'est pas une
question d'argent parce que j'ai gagné
très très bien ma vie à la télévision
d'accord alors là je vais essayer de
reprendre parce que ma sollicité donc je
vais peut-être reprendre et bien merci
Babette de Rosières je le rappelle donc
le livre La face cachée de la politique
en Île-de-France sortira le 27 avril
prochain aux éditions hors fils très
intéressant
alors on va parler maintenant de
secourisme officiellement créé en 1892
la Croix Blanche a pour mission
d'assurer la sécurité des populations
sur des rassemblements et de former au
secourisme dans les Yvelines en 2022
l'association était présente sur 200
postes de secours et à former plus de
4500 personnes je vous propose d'écouter
Bernard dabas le président départemental
de la Croix Blanche au micro de micro de
Julien Leroy
[Musique]
c'est de promouvoir le secourisme à
travers et des secours opérationnels
donc tous les secouristes de la Croix
Blanche sont
qualifiés PS1 PSE2 monde dans les
ambulances et font les secours la
deuxième mission de la croix blanche
mais c'est effectivement de promouvoir
le secourisme à travers des formations
donc formation que nous effectuons pour
tout type de population
[Musique]
de rester dans le domaine du secourisme
et ne pas agir sur la partie médicale là
effectivement c'est le rôle du Samu
d'intervenir
à tous les niveaux on donne une
attestation de formation mais chez les
enfants il y a un petit diplôme
puisqu'on fait on forme tous les classes
de CM1 de Saint-Cyr-l'École pour les
particuliers civils qui ont besoin du
PSC1 prévention ce cours civique de
niveau 1 ils en ont besoin pour des
qualifications sportives ou pour
un travail quelconque ben effectivement
ils reçoivent un diplôme et pour le
secourisme du travail il y a une petite
carte sauveteur secouriste du travail
qui est valable deux ans
[Musique]
les gens qui savent faire les gestes
c'est bien mais si c'est moi qui tombe
dans la rue j'aimerais bien
effectivement que chaque personne que je
suis amené à croiser que ça soit un
enfant un adulte un senior soit capable
d'effectuer les premiers gestes en plus
en plus en ma conviction personnelle
c'est qu'effectivement ça va aussi dans
le cadre du civisme et de la citoyenneté
on va maintenant ouvrir une page sport
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et Michael et le midoro vous allez
m'accompagner sur cette actualité
sportive on commence avec de la course à
pied on va prendre la direction de
Trappes pour parler de course à pied la
ville à organiser ce dimanche matin semi
à Marathon pour cette 4e édition plus de
350 coureurs c'était donné rendez-vous
malgré la pluie à montage de Sandrine
fontaine
les conditions climatiques nous les ont
pas découragées plus de 350 coureurs se
sont donnés rendez-vous ce dimanche 23
avril à Trappes pour participer aux 10
km au semi-marathon de la commune un
événement qui fêtait sa 4e édition
quelques uns ont dû annuler à la
dernière minute en raison de la météo
mais malgré tout c'est une belle fête
populaire du sport à Trappes qui a
organisé à l'occasion de ses courses pas
seulement pour courir mais également
pour encore une fois mettre en avant les
vertus du sport pour le 10 km Sébastien
Jacobs qui l'emporte en 32 minutes et 56
secondes du côté des féminines ces flore
Mertens qui terminent première en 40
minutes et 30 secondes je suis contente
je cours en club donc je suis entraîné
sur cette distance là 10 km c'est un
parcours assez roulant et bon malgré la
pluie mais voilà je suis satisfaite
après 21,1 km d'effort entre les rues de
la commune et l'île de loisirs de 50 ans
en Yvelines c'est jeudi Charenton qui
remporte le semi-marathon
je suis heureux c'est ma première fois
ici cette course était un peu difficile
avec la pluie aujourd'hui je suis
heureux d'avoir gagné
la première féminine Anastasia Louis
Joseph a bouclé quand elle le
semi-marathon en 1h28 et 39 secondes
tout le monde pourrait se retrouver
l'année prochaine à l'occasion d'une
nouvelle édition du semi-marathon de
Trappes la course devrait se dérouler à
la même période en espérant cette
fois-ci le soleil
[Musique]
et on continue ses résultats sportifs
avec vous amical et minero et il y avait
du football en National Versailles c'est
fait a très peur mais Versailles est
toujours en course pour la montée en
Ligue 2 les joueurs de crise sont
arrachés la victoire dans les toutes
dernières secondes du match face à ce
don grâce à un but du gardien Sébastien
Renault score final 2 1 à l'extérieur au
classement les Versailles sont toujours
à la 5e place du championnat à 4 points
du premier Concarneau il y a un point du
second Marty qui compte un match en
moins il reste quatre matchs dans ce
championnat de National et on va
descendre d'une division on va parler du
championnat de National 2 troisième
défaite de suite pour l'AS Poissy
l'épiciers se sont lourdement inclinés à
domicile sur le score de 3-1 face au
Racing Club de France le club Orchester
6 buts en deux matchs au classement le
club evinois qui avait très bien débuté
le championnat dégringole à la sixième
place et voit le podium s'éloigner
presque définitivement le bilan de
Poissy 12 victoires 5000 et 8 défaites
en 25 matchs et on change le sport un
petit mot sur le handball 20e journée du
championnat de National 2 à bien ce
week-end mauvais opération pour laisse
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les inhymontaines
se sont inclinés 31 à 29 à l'extérieur
sur le terrain du leader Béthune une
défaite logique qui pourrait condamner
les illinoises à terminer à la cinquième
place du championnat il reste encore
deux matchs d'ici la fin de la saison la
prochaine rencontre sera aussi à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de buis et
les mines et on va parler de tennis
maintenant le traditionnel classement
ATP a évolué ce lundi ce n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour notre yvelinois
Arthur rindernech longtemps dans le top
50 mondial sportifs originaire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye désormais 80e
joueur mondial la raison blessée il n'a
plus jouée depuis mars et sa défaite à
Miami on espère le voir à Roland-Garros
prochainement le tournoi débutera le 28
mai à prochain et on va faire un tour du
côté du rugby les phases finales de
Fédérale 2 débute ce dimanche de CLEMI
minois vont y participer plaisir et
Versailles les versets se déplaçant ce
dimanche à 15h sur le terrain de Creusot
et plaisir recevra au stade Robert
Barran l'équipe de Saint-Claude selon
les spécialiste nos deux clubs yvelinois
sont favoris de ces rencontres on leur
soit évidemment bonne chance
on va maintenant parler de volley-ball
et plus précisément d'un club qui a fait
une très belle saison le club de
Conflans Andrez Andrésy Jouy les
Illinois ont remporté à domicile la
Coupe de France fédérale et ils sont
deuxième des playoff pour nous parler de
cette saison de cette saison nous avons
avec nous le président Philippe
montaudoin et Thomas Nagel attaquant en
deux pointes
nuggles pardon Nagel alors ma première
question la suivante est-ce que vous
attendiez justement à cette saison
Thomas moi personnellement arrivant
d'Ajaccio donc du monde professionnel
retourner dans le monde amateur voilà je
m'attendais à à rien et j'ai juste été
surpris en fait et c'est voilà c'est une
saison qui restera dans l'histoire du
club et dans la dans la tête de tous les
joueurs es-tu Président je pense
Philippe
il parle d'amateur
on est quand même pas loin du
professionnalisme on est plutôt semi-pro
et on a costume un beau groupe on a bien
recruté on a des cadres un stage qui qui
ont fait vraiment gros boulot donc
normalement on devait avoir des
résultats bon après jusqu'à aller gagner
cette coupe c'était pas écrit d'avant on
avait quand même une très belle équipe
avec 12 joueurs interchangeables c'est
quand même intéressant de pouvoir
changer quasiment quand on veut et puis
un staff quand même assez étoffé
derrière vous
entraîneur en train de rejoindre
opérateur physique l'ostéopathe enfin
voilà donc on est dans un monde qui est
plus tout à fait amateur mais très
amateur quand on regarde les belles
images quand vous avez retransmises la
semaine dernière et quand le public
vient voir les joueurs pour les
féliciter en famille voilà
Philippe quand on voit cette Coupe de
France qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
c'est peut-être peut-être le plus beau
trophée de l'histoire du club est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment là alors en
termes de niveau c'est alors déjà c'est
le premier trophée le premier titre du
côté senior masculin on a déjà eu des
trophées chez les jeunes on était à
Coupe de France Benjamin il y a quelques
années
finalise de Coupe de France junior on a
gagné la Coupe de France fédérale
Nationale 3 chez les féminines parce
qu'on a avec le féminin également et on
avait on avait perdu celle-là il y a
quelques années avec Clermont-Ferrand
des beaux souvenirs donc ça y est on a
un vrai titre enseignant masculin donc
c'est effectivement c'est ça fait
vraiment plaisir Thomas ça vous fait
quoi de voir cette coupe à côté de vous
maintenant que je la vois ouais c'est
c'est des beaux souvenirs petite
déception elle est pas très étanche mais
après voilà ça reste ça reste un beau
souvenir et puis elle a déjà fait le
tour de nos partenaires elle a fait le
tour de tous les joueurs des familles
donc c'est des beaux souvenirs et pour
longtemps on racontera pas les détails
de la troisième mi-temps le groupe vit
bien si je comprends bien Philippe c'est
ça aussi l'objectif que vous étiez fixé
en début de saison il y avait un choix
qui a été fait sur les joueurs pour pour
leur sérieux pour savoir que ils
allaient s'engager parce que nous on
s'engage aussi et puis
il y a une très bonne entente je pense
il y a pas de
ça se passe très bien moi alors après
ils sont complètement cassés il faut
dire qu'ils sont les deux matchs là de
2h40 2h17 2 jours de suite avec un peu
de repos une petite nuit là on a des
blessés partout et bon on va jouer
d'ailleurs le leader Reims leader des
play-off samedi avec une équipe un peu
ratée c'est toute pièce mais bon voilà
on aura bien aimé avoir les deux le
titre de champion de France élite et
puis la coupe mais bon déjà c'est déjà
un bel exploit
et on a l'impression que le club montant
puissance depuis quelques années comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquez on travaille
très bonne réponse
on a derrière ce travail c'est 40
bénévoles déjà la semaine dernière qui
sont investis pendant déjà une dizaine
de jours avant un coup de réunion de
compte-rendu et puis c'est un club
semi-pro mais où on a toute une batterie
de gens qui ont les enfants enfin il y a
une vraie dynamique qui s'est créée
alors bien entendu les résultats font
venir du monde on est à 400 plus de 400
licenciés cette année moi j'en ai autant
on a renforcé toute la communication on
a renforcé le pôle partenariat puisque
Thomas s'en occupe
partenariats vous êtes aidé par des
entreprises locales comment ça se passe
oui et puis plus on est aidé et plus ça
marche c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
dynamique puis c'est vrai que derrière
le ce qu'on appelle partenariat avec
nous ils sont ils sont très heureux de
pouvoir avoir des informations
permanentes toutes les semaines ils
savent tous les résultats ils savent que
s'ils ont mis un euro dans ce club il y
a des enfants qui ont été joués sur le
sable à tel endroit que les filles la
semaine dernière ont joué contre
Carpiquet que l'équipe nationale de
garçons parce qu'on est national de
l'état de gagner à Caudry tout seul le
savent et puis derrière on a bon bah des
réseaux sociaux qui sont utilisés
on va dire à bon escient on a la chance
d'avoir aussi une Community Manager pour
l'instant qui est encore bénévole mais
qui pourrait peut-être évoluer aussi
dans le club parce que on s'aperçoit que
finalement
donner la chance à des jeunes qui font
un apprentissage je vais ça nous apporte
beaucoup moi je pense qu'on leur apporte
aussi par parce qu'on est déjà une idée
au bout de une trentaine d'années de
présidence de comment ça se passe le
volley-ball dans un club comme le nôtre
mais derrière il y a des qui amène aussi
leur dynamisme et en particulier tout ce
qui est réseaux sociaux et c'est vrai
que si vous regardez tous les 15 jours
notre équipe elle est visible en direct
avec des lives commentées enfin voilà on
est nos partenaires sont visibles le
globe est très visible presque
professionnel finalement presque
tu nous manque il nous manque voilà
ou deux gros investisseurs qui
viendraient
parcourir faire un parcours avec nous
s'associer à l'aventure parce que
honnêtement on est on est prêt oui et
après ce qui manque juste c'est ce gap
là pour pour passer au niveau pro tout
le monde sera là l'année prochaine
Président j'ai posé peut-être la
question déjà Thomas est-ce que vous
serez là la saison prochaine moi je
serai là avec le président du coup que
avec plaisir que je continue déjà la
partie sportive et aussi la partie
administrative comme il l'a dit comme
l'a dit Philippe je suis en alternance
dans le club donc dans la recherche de
partenariats et la fidélisation et c'est
un projet qui m'a énormément plu j'ai
tout de suite accroché la ville est top
et donc avec plaisir que que je continue
et vous êtes deuxième du coup pour
l'instant cette année en playoff
l'objectif ça sera quoi l'année
prochaine Thomas premier
merci Thomas Nagel c'est Philippe
Montaudon on continuera évidemment à
suivre votre club dans le futur
[Applaudissements]
alors on continue cette fois-ci donc les
5 et 6 mai aura lieu la finale de
championnats de France de badminton au
Palais des Sports d'Élancourt et pour en
parler avec nous Éric Mayer vous êtes le
président du comité d'organisation des
play-offs comment se déroule ces deux
jours donc ces deux jours on va avoir
donc
les quatre meilleures équipes françaises
qui vont venir à Élancourt donc ils se
sont départagés sur 10 journées de
championnat les deux premiers de chaque
foule donc sont qualifiés demi-finale
croisée donc le vendredi et final pour
des services de champion de France Top
12 de badminton le samedi est-ce qu'on
peut rappeler ces quatre équipes
justement donc un Chambly Arras
Fos-sur-Mer et Mulhouse et comment est
le niveau à peu près comment vous le
jugez les joueurs qui vont dire je pense
qu'on sont à peu près tous dans le top
100 mondial au niveau de leur de leur
spécialité
c'est vraiment
là on aura un très très gros plateau
unique non puisque on a déjà organisé
les finales Top 12 en 2009
c'était pas la même le badminton n'avait
pas la même
[Musique]
l'impact en fait on était un petit peu
moins connu donc là maintenant je pense
que c'est réellement à une vitrine pour
le club Élancourt pour la ville
d'Élancourt et donc
on espère faire un très bel événement
pour montrer que la badminton est un
sport très très intéressant
on a sentiments que ça se démocratise
vraiment le badminton on envoie un petit
peu de partout genre les JO aussi qui
vont peut-être aider à la promotion du
badminton ce que vous en pensez c'est
vrai que bon déjà le badminton au niveau
scolaire devenir des premiers sports
scolaires donc évidemment tout le monde
a fait du badminton dans les lycée ou au
collège donc déjà ça apporte du monde
dans le dans les clubs
après il nous manquait peut-être des des
résultats comment savoir des résultats
en double mix on a une équipe qui est
une paire française qui est cinquième
mondiale donc on commence à avoir
quelques résultats
si on pouvait faire des supers résultats
aux JO en France je pense que là ça
serait réellement un très beau tremplin
et alors justement ce titre champion de
France donnera le droit au vainqueur de
représenter la France lors de la Coupe
d'Europe des Clubs
le champion
défendra les odeurs de la France en
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs donc les
dernières c'était Chambly qui avait le
titre et alors défendre son titre et
alors combien de personnes seront
attendues les 5 et 6 mai alors on a la
chance d'être dans un
palais des sports d'Élancourt qui 1200
places donc on espère remplir le Palais
des Sports donc les billets sont en
vente sur sur le site du de l'événement
donc je qui sont d'ailleurs affichés
voilà donc on attend on attend un
maximum de monde
on espère avoir c'est vrai qu'on est
pendant les vacances donc les gens
devraient pouvoir venir le vendredi sans
problème pour voir les finales et puis
le samedi sera vraiment une belle fête
derrière donc
on attend un maximum de monde il y avait
combien de personnes là en 2009 on
n'avait pas eu énormément de monde je
crois qu'on avait fait presque plus pas
plus de 200 entrées sur le week-end mais
je vous dis c'était pas le même le même
le même impact le badminton et surtout
les équipes qui viennent là on a
vraiment des très très bons joueurs
donc là je pense qu'on s'arrête un très
beau spectacle est-ce que c'est vraiment
pour tout le monde vraiment tout le
monde peut venir ah oui oui tout à fait
c'est un des un espérant bon on prend le
plaisir le plus vite on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir un niveau énorme pour faire du
pour avoir pour prendre plaisir
Wellington et donc c'est pour ça que
beaucoup de monde accrochent badminton
on a dans le club des sections
compétitions donc là évidemment on a
besoin d'avoir des entraînements etc
pour arriver à un bon niveau mais on a
les section loisirs qui marche très bien
et donc déjà si tous les joueurs de
badminton de l'Île-de-France viennent
on se rend compte
en tout cas merci beaucoup Eric Mayer de
nous avoir partagé ce moment je le
rappelle vous êtes le président du
comité régional des playoffs de
badminton et maintenant on va parler de
football et avec vous Michael et demi
d'euro à partir du côté de
Clairefontaine le Centre national
d'entraînement a accueilli pendant 3
jours les finales des coupes de France
des grandes écoles à Saint-Gobain
Football Cup a réuni des étudiants de
l'Hexagone des images de Grégory Kanami
concentration maximale pour les 450
joueurs et joueuses présents ce jour-là
au centre national d'entraînement de
Clairefontaine ces sportif participent à
la Saint-Gobain Football Cup c'est final
organisé du 21 au 23 avril regroupe les
meilleures écoles d'ingénieurs et de
commerce de France le niveau est très
élevé pour être honnête là on sait que
il y a vraiment pas le droit à l'erreur
le niveau est très très fort en face
mais il s'est stimulant du coup il y a
un bon esprit de compétition je trouve
et un bon fair-play du fair-play aussi
des rivalités entre les structures sur
le terrain les 24 équipes venues des
quatre coins de la France veulent gagner
pour leur école c'est un peu comme le
derby ou le derby le classico entre
Paris et Marseille quoi on sent qu'il y
a une recherche de victoire une envie de
gagner et puis surtout de gagner ici à
Clairefontaine au-delà de la spé sportif
l'événement aussi pour objectif de faire
rêver ses étudiants depuis 11 ans les
organisateurs investissent ce lieu
d'entraînement de l'équipe de France
cette année pendant trois jours la magie
a une nouvelle fois opérée on a toutes
les deux joué en club on a toutes les
deux fêtes du foot pendant longtemps
c'est une expérience qui est vraiment
unique je pense que c'est un privilège
d'être là et on s'est battu pour être là
avec notre équipe en école c'est génial
il y a des supers installations à chaque
fois quand on regarde les rassemblements
des Bleus on voit les joueurs et
débarquer sur les fameuses escaliers on
est l'opportunité de visiter les locaux
de s'entraîner de voir ce que vous
pouvez vivre les joueurs la cantine tout
en fait elle a même des kinés qui sont
là disposition pour nous masser les
petites jambes c'est assez fabuleux
cette 11e édition a sacré l'INSA Lyon
chez les hommes et les femmes pour les
ingénieurs pour les écoles de commerce
les deck Lille chez les filles et
Grenoble chez les garçons l'emportent
rendez-vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition dans les Yvelines et
bien merci Mickaël midoro pour ces
résultats sportifs ylinois c'est bientôt
la fin de cette émission mais juste
avant de se quitter je vous propose de
jeter un dernier coup d'œil à la météo
de demain
[Musique]
et le temps sera nuageux demain matin
avec des éclaircies dans tout le
département selon Météo France au niveau
des températures il fera encore un peu
frais le matin comptez 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 7 degrés à Versailles et
ou dans les 6 degrés à Rambouillet on
retrouvera les mêmes conditions météo
dans l'après-midi et côté température
elles aussi entre 11 et 12 degrés dans
tout le département et demain nous
fêterons la Saint Marc et c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 je vous remercie pour votre
fidélité et on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition
[Musique]